je te rappeler que le béton mal aimée
est le seul matériau non spéculatif au
monde puisque chacun de pays dans le
monde produisent en béton autant dire
autant du bois dont on découvrira car
même qui a des filières spéculative et
des assauts manipulateur et notamment
sur des interdits des formations je veux
pas faire monter le ton du débat mais
tout de même fini tu peux pas faire des
dégaines ascenseur coupe feu avec du
bois tu peux pas faire des plots chic de
la masse acoustique avec du bois tu peux
pas faire il ya des départs mécanique de
l'ouvragé dont tu sais très bien qu elle
peut pas être en bois
ce n'est pas possible et moi le sujet
qui m'a qui m'intrigue dans le bois
c'est la notion de distance tu parlais
de distante le béton il est toujours
produits dans un rayon de 30 kilomètres
par rapport à l'endroit où on ne
m'utilise tous les cas c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça dans de nombreux pays et
je moi je m'interroge sur les distances
parcourues par le bois pour venir
d'autriche
je m'interroge sur l'étuvage sur les
routes température par danone de
nombreux heurts ont donné une stabilité
mécanique au moi je m'encourage
je m'interroge aussi sur la colle
utilisée en le ccar mais le tout n'est
pas clean pas s'interroger aussi sur les
lobbys qui sont faits au niveau
législatif pour démanteler la filière de
car même un million d'emplois autour des
industries du béton et convenant tout de
même que le béton est devenue une
définition générique mais qu'il faut
arrêter de lui faire le procès de ce qui
fut dans les années 60 comme si on nous
faisait encore le procès du colonialisme
[Musique]